das ist böse hat jetzt seine motion
trank alter wo er hat er das alles so
halloren alle zur nächsten runde von
händel bis 4
das ist jetzt die dritte dritten
durchlauf die ersten waren also
durchwachsen so vielleicht wachsen so
ein bisschen nicht immer so ganz optimal
aber auch nicht ganz so schlecht
irgendwie man schmeißt mit 70 gegen ich
weiß nicht warum das problem ist die
organisation steht eigentlich nur keiner
zu ja das ist halt das blöde der halo an
deine zuschauer wir machen jetzt wir
hatten schon zwei runden von den hast du
glaub ich beide jetzt schon hoch geladen
zu diesem zeitpunkt ich habe sozusagen
weil die erste war bei mir sieben
minuten und ich keine lust etwas zu
lernen er also die sind jeweils nur vier
minuten lang war die situation vor allem
wenn man mit fäusten oder den knoten
3play zb faust stand da vor mir
anstatt okay wir bleiben du bist im
spiel jeder kümmert sich um seine
sammlung paar kisten dann haut er geht
mit fäusten auf mich los im klub nicht
platt also ja du kannst doch von hinten
schwertern da mag gleichen gar nicht
sofort abbauen können das strategisch
druck drauf klappen wenn wir versuchen
es strategisch auch zu machen
das heißt man meinen die aufnahme läuft
jetzt gerade oder sollte jetzt gestartet
werden der die map jetzt auch gleich
gestalteten extra countdown noch dann
geht's los die am strategie ausgedacht
ist wieder drei minuten ist grace period
und dann treffen sie am spot also
doppelt ist glaube ich eine gute gehen
wo direkten diaz wert bekommt es nach
ein paar minuten ja bei mir ist es so
dass wegschnappt also an meine zuschauer
wir machen jetzt gerade mit teams die
letzten beiden runden ohne teams partner
im team da hinten ist ein gebäude das
seht ihr meine aufnahme jetzt da läuft
dann einfach rüber da ist sondern
drahtseil wenn man nach oben drüber
läuft zum ist da hinten den turm da ist
rüstung und
stein schwer da will ich erst mal hin
aber ich denke auch ich werde am anfang
erstmal die kisten dingens mitnehmen da
hab den diamanten rausgeholt nicht
schade ich habe nie gekriegt gut da muss
ich rotieren ich hab schon dass sie
eingepackt wird wer schmeißt den ganzen
müll herum
ich habe deine 13 gesammelt dadurch
hätten diamanten am anfang kriegen
müssen habe ich nicht gekriegt mussten
alternative route nehmen
ok wollen wir uns dann beim spawn wieder
treffen können wir wieder treffen nach
drei minuten ich hab hier nebenbei so
ein halbe stoppuhr laufen eine million
verweist wie ein gepard noch ist dass er
auch immer witzig ist ich meine in den
ersten beiden runden die wir bisher
gemacht haben immer mein michi und luke
lp haben sofort am anfang die
erschwerten alles also ich glaube die
haben wirklich die komplette web
studiert ich bin wirklich andere durch
geflogen ein paar kisten angeguckt habe
so geguckt daher wo könnte ich ungefähr
hin laufen wo könnten kisten sein und
ich glaube manche leute die haben das
echt alles genauestens durch gabe ja ich
bin ich will mal durchgang abgeguckt
ungefähr mit der die erschwerte die habe
ich mir zum beispiel auch angeschaut
jetzt hatten wir tatsächlich noch das
eisen geklaut müsste mich also das eisen
schwert kannst du vergessen ja da mehr
geschneit hatte sich weggeschnappt
oder die wahl doch vielleicht vielleicht
doch ich habe noch eine andere route
vielleicht gibt es doch noch der typ
hier oben auch pixel architekt bis das
glaube ich setze jetzt auch schon die
kitze geschnappt zu der ich vorhin
gelaufen bin und man schade wenn ich
glück gehabt kriege ich jetzt noch ein
diamant und wenn ich glück wenn er jetzt
rennt ihren urlaub noch lange will sich
auch wieder ein diamant oder sie auch
schnell sein geschaffen ja du wolltest
du gerade
ich bin da nicht runtergefallen erwärmt
du bist du wirst du ich gehe jetzt aber
nicht noch mal hin
ich verziehe mich gerade mal und sorgte
entwickeln gar nicht wie ich bin jetzt
am bahnhof bald bei dem haus ich bin
nicht laufen bisschen weiter in die
stadt rein und zwar zu einer
entsprechenden stelle wo man noch gute
sachen abgreifen kann
es hat keinen sinn oder wollen sie erst
mal treffen kommt ich habe kaum noch ich
habe noch hälfte von herzen welchem
runtergefallen bin hoffentlich bekommt
wird wieder total der fehler ja wir
haben kommen hast sie schnappen sich
alles weg wo bist du
ich laufe jetzt in richtung zu diesem
feuerwehrhaus weil obendrauf ist ein
bogen mit power plus 1 zu weit ich weiß
definieren wie sieht das feuerwehr
aus dass dieses parcours in europa wolle
rota wolle und in diesen play an den
wänden okay gut dann komme ich dahin
treffen uns einfach jung aufgestellt
welche immer paranoia hat das mich immer
verfolgt das nächste halbe minute der
erste schaffen dass wir dann zusammen
sind also ich hab mich mal schwerer
rüstung
ich habe eine hose und tierische pilze
kräften und die kiste oben schon leer
dazwischen jemand geschnappt heißt der
bogen zwischen weg hinter dieser hier
links ich hab noch ein herzchen geld
kannst du vielleicht etwas bringen oder
so ich verstecke mich oben was man auf
ich schmeiße dir mal kurz hier pilz
runter bloßen schale graf mit einem haus
irgendwie pilzsuppe dann werde ich mich
halten kann ich habe noch ein herzchen
ich kann nichts machen ich muss hier
stimmt einerseits bin ich dir deine
piste hier rumlaufen willst ja ich
gleich auch damit mich keiner sehen kann
meine lebens an zwei geräten ich habe
nur noch ein häschen das flammenmeer
runter gefallen ich weiß gar nicht wo
kriegt man den hin kräftig wenn ich
merke auch rathaus wieder leben in das
haus hier daneben da gibt es in grafing
table das rote backsteinhaus da sondern
es andere einmal rundherum oft anderen
seite wurde gerade bist hinter diesem
gebäude wurde war glaub ich stehe wo ich
dir ja ich wollte aber trotzdem war ein
engel sein rating table so schnell dass
es anderen seite hinter mir hinter
diesem gebäude wo ich habe ja moment
genommen weg ich komme da schon
irgendwie irre da geht's hoch
ok ich mich messen oder auch bitte womit
das andere gebäude rein moment weil man
kann ganz geschmeidig da genau am
richtigen wirklich sehen dann nahm ich
kann nicht sehen
das gebäude da drüben rein dass auch
eine kiste hast du dich schon gesehen
habe ich nicht gesehen ich will welche
runter für mich tod hier in das gebäude
genau da wo ich jetzt an die gäste aber
da kommt man nicht anlegen doch da ist
was eine schande und ein schwert
man kann hier sogar zwei puppen machen
versucht irgendwie darum runterzukommen
oder geht das nicht geht nicht wenn ich
jetzt oben nochmal versucht zu springen
sterbe ich weil ich dann hielt sie
können uns doch nicht zwei pilze machen
ja nur eine wegen finster aus für gut
wenn ich die krieg ich bin gleich tot
neue hoffnung die halt genug herzchen
dass ich die leben laden zum glück bin
ich so sozial
so gaben seine zwar gegenseitig
irgendwann helfe ich dir noch am ende
setzen
so bekommt oder seine kiste moment die
ja warte erstmal mit einem messer
fachmann ruhig das war die kiste aber
die wird hundertprozentig auch schon
leer sein
und sie ist leer hat eigentlich eine
neue map draufgepackt
ja es ist neu bisher waren fast alle
kisten die ich hatte leer
soll ich dir jetzt hoch bringen da
hinten war eine leiter geklettert ist
der kann so klettere nie mehr runter
schmeißen
weil ich will sich riskiere mich jetzt
hoch klettern und dann darf das dach
springen das stellt er sagen wir gehen
allgemein defensiv vor und warten darauf
dass ein paar leute sterben oder
irgendwie ja dann dass man so die reste
einsammeln und dann genau ich gehe noch
eine gute stelle wo man einiges an zeit
bekommen da muss man ein bisschen jumpen
da brauchen wir auch hunger das heißt
wir kommen uns erstmal nahrung am besten
gut ich hoffe die halt genau jetzt
erwartet so leben laden leben laden ich
das kurze leben laden es nicht mehr geht
hier ich würde sagen wir treffen uns da
unten bei dem gebäude wieder kräftig der
bewahrt euch ja und am besten oder
bleibt man dastehen trug mal shift und
schleichen oder oder oder gemacht da
shift weil nicht dass wir gesehen werden
schon gleich wollen wir erstmal durch
die oder hinter seine kiste table tennis
game wussten beide noch jahre hat wieder
sein die ihr schwert könnte ich werde
mich da an die abgegriffen und ansporn
hat auch schon die abgegriffen was weiß
ich nämlich dass mir vor meinen kiste
gesprungen da oben drauf ist eine kiste
aber ich fange ich halte mich doch
diesen weg kommt für sie lesen
ladenstraße pilze siehst dann sag mir
bitte direkt bescheid weil ich habe ja
und jetzt noch die schale
und ich brauche definitiv auch noch was
zu essen gleich es gibt eine stelle da
gibt es noch pilze ja lange das sieht
und dann bat tod war okay ich bin
rumgekommen aber meine hunde anzeige ist
noch am flackern
ich bin laden den lebenssinn 14 fehlen
noch dann komme ich weiter verpiss dich
tag spaß einander näherkommen hirtz
bisschen sozial müssen wir schon halten
ist ja das ist halt das publikum so am
besten sich mehr sprinten weil jungen
zeige sehr linear ist auf seite
ja ich extra mit hier zu mir erwartet
geht immer dahin nicht sicher auch glück
ist aber die wird auch hundertprozentig
leer sein weil ich vorhin als ich hier
durch geflogen waren ja auch geile
sachen drin da gibt's sogar die die ok
ich hab' ich hab ihn schwert leverkusen
zwei pfeile ich finde als entschuldigung
dafür dass ich gerettet habe solltest du
mir die push geben
die boots ja gut gar nicht machen
hier unten ist der kanalisation weil wir
hier eingehen ja da will ich ja gerade
hin dass da zieht dass er daraufhin aus
david muss ich mich ausziehen und die
anziehen hast du schon jayne hose oder
die stinken aber er habe ich das das
einzige was am anfang abgegriffen habe
so hier sind geheimen kann was man auch
hier vorne müssen eine kiste seiner
gibt's pilz unter anderem da können wir
mal hingehen ich hoffe man diese noch da
das heißt wir gehen hier ein kleines
stückchen und sagen und dann da vorne
links gleich als erstes und eine kiste
im boden und dann müssten eisen drin
sein und fisch glaube ich pilze auf
jeden fall genug bodin abreisen und
fisch war dass wir das also weißt ja ich
bin auch schon mal durch ein klar was
denkst du denn es gibt schon party an
die mep durchgespielte gestern war schon
live stream also ich bin jetzt am
samstag haben schon welche teamleistung
gespielt hast als abgegriffen alles ja
ich gewürze zum crafting date treffen
uns einfach wieder lebhaft noch was
besseres finden müsste noch ein eisen
theoretisch sein
ach so wurden da reihenfolge mich folge
mich dass auch ein geheimgang wodurch
können dann nochmals haus rein guckt gut
ich glaube ich sollte auch mehr gucken
dann stelle ich mich nach einer minute
ja das ist mal so total witzig erzählen
willst wissenspark art von text
geschrieben den 60
durch lesen wo der regeln stand steht
drin damit ihr nicht nach einer minute
stirbt an wechselnde grace period
aktiviert ich so alter auf jeden
wolltest du da hinaus naja das war
absolut dicht voll ausgelastet ist
du weißt du was ihr denkt an alle wer
jetzt das wiederum eine kiste ist eine
portion of zwölfte gegeben ach so was
drin war holte reisen drin ja ich
brauche ein stock aber okay pass mal auf
ich glaube mal ein bisschen hier sind
geheimgang hast den stock ich hab' ich
stecke da ich denke drin war wieder
offen doch okay ist wenn ich im haus gut
bekannt schon schaden bekommen so ich
habe einen stick übrigens für eisen
schwertmeister da wussten crafting label
hier drin ist noch keiner der kommt noch
kommst du gerade mit ihr gibt es glaube
ich auch nix ist zappenduster hier ist
nochmal gallengang einmal zum durchgehen
und jetzt auch noch eine kiste wird noch
keine haben wir sind helden drin in
eisen helm und 3 weeks sind drin das
heißt da kann ich mir noch ein brot
greifen zum essen so ich habe motion auf
swissness zwei damit dürfte es ab diesen
wie sonst was hast du noch so eine essen
schale oder brauchst du ein ja ich habe
eine gut wir brauchen crafting table und
west zu essen machen
ich habe noch fünf leder wohin willst
landen lederriemen vielleicht kraft
gegeben was man auch dann können wir
hier emergency exit den hier nehmen
dagegen wird hier oben das ding
aufgemacht mehr ausgehen
warte mal kurz wie es bis zum
mechanismus so ja ich da draußen sie mir
im haus drin und können hier vorne
wieder ums andere haus rein und raus
gekommen sind
da war perfekte richtig das ist einmalig
ich hab mich ein bisschen ein bisschen
angeschaut ich habe auch in den
informations 6 und rein geschrieben weil
einige das auch schon vorher aufgenommen
haben ich weiß euch darauf hin dass ihr
euch die map anschaut und euch eine
strategie zurecht legt weil das viele
andere auch schon machen werden also
habe ich auch fett gedruckt geschrieben
denn wir dass jeder liest versteht ihr
sohn jett okay gut
sap habe ich dir gemacht und brot
das macht den leser in cannes gegeben
klopp eine suppe jetzt muss mir das ipad
geben du hast das schwert oder warte ich
kann dir das hier geben
ich habe heute gelernt hast du zwei
holzschwerter es verdiene gut
ausgleichen schnecke hat kurz davor eine
schere zu machen
nee hab ich einfach nicht geht es gut
es gibt auch eine stelle wo einigermaßen
gut was gibt wollen wir da mal analysen
der garten namen ja da ist ein name
relativ nah das ist mister outback
letzten leg dich mal ganz kurz kommen zu
mir rüber da sind tief 1 gegen die nazis
ja ich sehe ich sehen wie ich verstecke
ich mal ganz gut im dunkeln war einfach
zu zweit auf den drauf gehen weil ich
hab jetzt vorleben so alles kann man
machen
okay gut also dass ist mister outback
ist von topshop media echt ich dachte es
wäre kilian ja mist outback auf ok das
haben sich abgewechselt ok tedi hat
machen doch jetzt angesagt die beiden
wochen zusammen q cells hin
ja ich würde sagen wir gehen hinten
durch den wald ok im wald simons glaube
ich auch noch eine geste verstehen sind
zwei kisten die habe ich auch gesehen
allerdings waren beide nichts drin weil
ich die allererste spiel versuchen
erstmal nicht zu sprinten geben die
jungen anzeige zu sparen übrigens dass
wir auch sagen könnten sie touristen
hatten wir angekündigt um die 3c kommen
und hier 30 das haben ja auch viele
gesagt warum hast du die 3c abgebrochen
das ist ja noch pausiert ich würde man
die andere richtung gehen weil da hinten
da hinten war noch eine kiste irgendwo
doch da ist auch eine aber dieses wird
hundertprozentig schon leer seien hätten
auch so ich bin dahin gegangen ist oder
was und sie ist voll ist ein schwert und
guckt fisch kann ich das tonc reinhard
mohn holz dann gib mir das holz sehr
schön das passt am eisen holz und ich
weiß dass da auf dem berg oben noch ein
bisschen rüstung glaube ich drin ist ein
bisschen equipment allgemein warum
dahingehend gibt das muss man halt ein
klein wenig jumpen grad bei ttc sind der
körper machen muss weiß hat bitte keine
leiter sprünge so im blog gemeldet dass
das netz nach dem hit the ground to
heart fraglich für die abos lane bei der
kef hätte ich sie nur zusammen team
recht hektisch schon es ist bloss rang
ich glaube ich kann dir für den anderen
draufgehauen der kampf hinaus in seinen
eigenen geschlagen allerdings noch
einige fallen ist extrem heftig ich
glaube hier gibt's der falle
dass der kreml runterfällt wenn du da
stehst und die kiste öffnet oder oder
einmal ans licht die kids habe ich schon
geöffnet da passiert nichts ergebnis
eine falle das weiß ich das lockt ist
wenn uns so einer sieht und trotzdem
keine anzugreifen weil du hast drei
rüstungsteile ich habe drei
rüstungsteile ich habe mein schwert
ersten stein schwert guck mal oben
siehst du da das helle da am berg oben
drin da ist ein gang
da ist eine große kiste mit vielen items
trennen ich glaube am flughafen brauchen
jetzt auch nicht chronisch hier vorne
ist eventuell könnte man da gucken hier
ziemlich eine falle ich weiß jemand rein
getraut hat hier vorne ist ein button an
der wand wenn du den text dann geht das
ding hier zu und lava kommt von oben
runter also nicht drücken wir gehen mal
ganz kurz rein kommen rein ich weiß auch
das kann er reingeht gucken hinterm
crafting cable da ist und eine kiste
drin ist er okay im flugzeug ist auch
noch eine kiste drin dass meine können
wir ganz kurz vielleicht noch nach einem
braunen jahr aber die wir im flugzeug
wird hundertprozentig auch leer sein was
man auf wolle gleich hoch gehen zu
großen also da oben rein zum berg dann
müsste man denke da werden auch schon
welche gewesen sein aber naja das war
das ziel einer party zum beispiel 30
minuten lang wird sie mit dem schneiden
ja dann haben sie zwei folgen das ist ja
dann auch dann wieder alle zwei tage da
die erste aufnahme waren fünf minuten
die 24 minuten 2004 man eben direkt
schon auf dass die erste gelöscht habe
wenn ich bei sieben minuten am leben und
gut ich sag mal so von der
aufmerksamkeitsspanne es eigentlich
sinnvoll nicht allzu lange videos
allgemein auf youtube zu machen
deshalb bat sollte nicht übermäßig lang
sein atem an wie geht es nun weiter
ich glaube momente ich hiermit hinter
mir her so so und dann hier oben die
ecke springen also man schon mal drin
genau jetzt aber so eine kleine jump vor
uns vom auch sprinten müssen was man
auch hier sind druck bleibt oben drauf
das heißt wenn du jetzt vertraut auf die
druckplatte verschwinden die blöcke
davor muss auf druck drauf sprinten
hinten abspringen versuchen hoch zu
kommen bevor die blöcke verschwinden ist
muss der staat springt und springt okay
du kannst dir rich auf der druckplatte
auch noch bevor ich hab losgegangen bin
ich schon ein kleines stück weiter hier
kann man rausgucken ich weiß nicht doch
da geht so immer ecke jetzt hat man oft
entsteht eine kiste bier doch schon her
sein
ich schaue mal kurz will ob die
fernrohre ob ich irgendwo spieler sehr
werden die die keine steuern noch
aufgefüllt
ich glaube nach der zweiten ab der
zweiten nacht kann man die auffüllen er
soll dann gibt's da entlang und die hoch
um die ecke genau erst mal kurz meinem
brot
ich bin jetzt hier was ist das jetzt
hier
wenn ihr es richtig ist richtig so
optimierten entlang dann die liane nach
oben
daher staatliche förderung und hier die
liane würde ich gerne abbauen weil die
darf mehr abbauen was man auf dann wird
man hier schön hoch springen können
ich nehme das schwerter sachen sonst bin
ich noch zu schwer botschaft geschafft
und die kiste ist leer hat sich nicht
gelohnt guck mal da war eisen schuhe
drin auch mal so viele nahrung alles
also doppel kiste sogar schade als muss
man träume dahinter hängen wo ich mal
kurz in schlage sich so wartet steht
unter den wald neuen formaten kommt
jemand einen flugplatz ja das ist nur ob
wir zu zweit auf den drauf gehen können
dass theoretisch schaffen wollen wir
okay weil ich weiss jemand einer stütze
die mir auch doof der läuft weg glaube
ich wenn er wegläuft
der pakt an pfeil aus und verändert mit
kopf geschüttelt
wie immer hat der dabei hier komponierte
reisen brustpanzer der schuhe komplette
ausrüstung
ich glaube der herr drexler später sagt
genommen damit wir denken dass er kein
schwert hat und wenn er hoch kommt kann
wir den eigentlich runterschubsen wenn
er nicht diesen bogen power hatte
brauchte zwei schüssen du bist weg und
ich glaube bei den nord ab ich glaube
der hat dass das wären der werfen auch
schon immer ganz gut weg kommen eine
angeflogen macht doch mal wenn ich nach
suhl wendisch fragezeichen 10 euro
aufstocken konkret nennt bestimmt nicht
okay
ob ich seinen namen ziemlich genau
bewusst sind
ich bin da runter gegangen ok ok ok ich
hab' ich es nicht er hat sich gelegt
also wirklich diesen boden facto après
ski was man auf wären wir am besten zum
flugzeug und zum flughafen wo wir gerade
sind
nein man wo bist du ich die neben dem
und der steht neben dem blog der musste
kurz um die ecke und ein pfeil
abschießen achtest du ich seh dich oh oh
ja das böse hat jetzt seinen posten
trank alter wohl hat er das alles hätten
die aschwer ich bin tot alter hey das
ist doch behindert wieso gibt es leute
die einfach keine hobbys haben sich die
map die ganze zeit angucken und wissen
wo brosens die ja schwer das total gut
habe ich vorausgesagt hat das machen
kann aber alter ich bin kurz über die
märkte wo ich meine es auch gestern noch
drei leute am leben ich wünsche dir viel
bekannt spectator
ja klar machen willst du bist am
flughafen ich verziehe mich irgendwo
hinter dem anlass doch alles geht
das sind so leute die spielen auch keine
ahnung wie viel die zocken
meine ich nicht wegrennen keller ist
nicht hinter dir gut der darf aber auch
nicht dann bescheid sagen zum beispiel
wo ich gerade umlauf also wir auch immer
da kann doch teilnimmt herumfliegt mein
mich ist ja echt ein typ der hat auch
vorhin als wieder alarm spawn stand und
halt schon tot waren und dann halt
spectator haben standen unsere avatare
ja oder unsere charaktere in minecraft
stand noch am spot- und er dann in
seinem fetten tnt brand ist in namibia
schwert und auch tot
ja also ich hab den jetzt nicht gesehen
oder nicht erwartet dass er noch kommt
ich hab mich verpissen sollen ganz
einfach
jetzt ging einst bester credits raum
ich muss auch mal die aufnahme beenden
ach so ja ich auch nicht beendet ich
habe jetzt einfach noch zugeguckt nur
noch stagniert bei mir gerade alter
guckt er war sein inventar an
ich halte ihn absolut die ja schwer
verzauberter bogen promotion streisand
schwert rüstung
er hat noch brot pfeile alles ja toll
apple hardware also macht das auch
keinen spaß wenn einer alles hat ja ich
meine den letzten 100 auch schon die
erschwert gehabt ruckelt mann bist mein
spectator man kann den ansehen
ich würde sagen ich beende jetzt mal
ganz kurz die aufnahme das war es jetzt
erstmal hier von survival games ich habe
jetzt den ersten part nicht hochgeladen
wo die anderen plan haben den zweiten
hab ich hochladen und jetzt den dritten
ich werde ihn auch in ein paar denke ich
hoffe also gesprächs keine zukunft
eigentlich hast es ja nicht gemacht aber
das video kommt das war schon ja genau
und dann wird sagen von mir erst mal
tschüss vielleicht gibt es irgendwann
noch mal sowas vielleicht werden wir
auch noch etwas anderes mit einer
anderen web denke wird auch ziemlich
geil werden und dann wird man eine map
nehmen die man selbst gemacht hat habe
ich mein erstes und andere öffentlich
ist die noch keiner gesehen außer man
selbst und dann wird so planen dann
spielen dass alle und er selbst beifall
die mitspieler ist oder ja ewig ich
denke an was komplett anderes diese idee
die wir vorhin auch im dingens hatten
das ist eine echte gleich weiß jetzt
schon so verraten soll
na ja ich will erst mal sein von mir aus
bis zum nächsten mal genossen